[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الجيش السوداني ينفذ
طلعات جويه في العاصمه السودانيه ومضادات
الدعم السريع ترد وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
تنقل عن دبلوماسيا سعودي ان مفاوضات جده
لوقف اطلاق النار لم تحرز تقدما كبيرا
والامم المتحده تقول ان مفاوضها لشؤون
الانسانيه سيركز خلال لقاءاته مع طرفين
على بحث القضايا الانسانيه
روسيا تكفف هجماتها على اوكرانيا باستخدام
عشرات المسيرات كيف تعلن تاهبا جويا في
عموم البلاد وتقول انها اسقطت اغلب
المسيرات الروسيه المهاجمه وتتهم موسكو
باستخدام الفوسفور في هجمات بخموت
عقب مباحثات بين وزير الخارجيه الصيني
وسفير واشنطن في الصين
تطالب واشنطن باحترام ما وصفته بخطها
الاحمر الاساسي وبالتوقف عن دعم انفصال
تايوان وسفير الامريكي يقر بالتنافس
الكبير بين البلدين ويقول ان واشنطن تسعى
لتحقيق التوازن وتعزيز وجودها العسكري في
المنطقه
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تحذر من ان اخفاق
الكونجرس في رفع سقف الدين يهدد بتخلف
الحكومه عن سداد ديونها لاول مره على
الاطلاق وبايدن يبحث مع زعيمي الجمهوريين
في مجلسي الشيوخ والنواب سبل حل الازمه
الى اللقاء